hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to getting over it with
Bennet Fadi now this is the latest and
greatest game made by the developer of
QWOP which means that this game is gonna
be totally fair not rage-inducing at all
and I'm gonna keep my sanity in this why
am i wearing a blanket also because it's
cold but I imagine that the burning hot
fires of Rage that I'm not gonna have
are gonna get me through this just fine
Mouse ah a rock Oh a hammer a chisel a
pike makka doodle a wumbly whoo a nice
pick a rock pick a pick I'm ready for
this come on ready to get over it come
on that's nice that ain't ready right
you know you look at something and you
just see something that's just not right
it's one of the cannons from a Donkey
Kong but man that ain't that ain't right
oh oh look at this dynamic animation
here oh I see I see I see okay I see how
you work Oh Oh young Oh let's just relax
here oh yes okay all right all right I
gotta launch myself
ah ha ha ha ha you can't beat me feeling
more intense than starting over if you
deleted your homework the day before it
was drew as I have or if you left your
wallet at home
you have to go back after spending an
hour in the commute if you want some
money at the casino and then put all
your winnings on red but it came up
lacking if you've got your best shirt
dry-cleaned before a wedding and then
immediately dropped a fruit on it if you
want an argument with a friend and then
later discovered that they just returned
to their original view starting over is
harder than starting up if you're not
ready for that Mike if you've already
had a bad day then what you're about to
go through might be too much
feel free to go away and come back what
I'll be here
wait what huh are you telling me that
I'm about to have a bad time all right
thanks for coming with me on this I
don't like this I'll understand if you
have to take a break at any point oh
don't worry I'll sort your progress
always even your mistake okay oh my god
[Music]
ahaha okay it's just an educational
experience I've got to learn before I
can crawl right ha
okay all right from this vantage point
I've got so much potential swung okay
swung no you're not swung and hard
enough okay all right it's like spank
the monkey Oh what crazy is this - a
free game that came out in 2002 boudic
see the author of that game was Jesuit a
mysterious Czech designer who is known
at the time as the father of B games and
be games a ruff assemblages of found
objects and they're often too rough and
unfriendly to gain much of a following
they're built more for the joy of
building them than his polished products
are they now hahaha dammit ok alright ok
ok well ho boy ah I was right the
burning hot fire rage in my heart who's
gonna get me through you just lost a lot
of progress that's a deep frustration a
real punch in the gut
oh is it oh is it now oh is it a punch
in the gut oh is it oh you don't know
nothing about gut-punching mister you
don't even have a gut you're just in a
freakin cauldron a witch got halfway
through brewing you and you you think
you can stand mmm tell me who I really
am Oh relax the grip investor there's a
time for quick movements and then
there's a time for gentle relaxation
Oh
okay all right you sack of [ __ ] okay all
right okay this is how you're gonna be
huh I know is that the thing you do Oh
left flailing I'm just left flailing her
oh oh god okay
all right I gotta get up this goddamn
Mountain oh my god is that sweat coming
off my body the water thing what is that
am I in a cauldron of water also why no
no yes yes yes no haha okay
made it made it thus far and that's good
oh no made it thus far and that's good
in a certain way embodiment of a be game
it's built almost entirely out of found
in recycled parts and it's one of the
most unusual and unfriendly games of its
time in it your task is simply to drag
yourself up a button with a hammer
oh that act of climbing in the digital
world or enjoy certain essential
properties that give the game its flavor
no amount of forward progress is
guaranteed some cliffs shiho too
slippery and the player is constantly
unremittingly in danger of falling and
no no stop tell moving stop barrels
he'll be Oh God
okay all right Oh like a monk gentle as
the Moon moves gentle is the summer
breeze yeah anyway when you stop sitting
standing next to this dead tree that
blocks the way to the entire it might
take you an hour to get over that tree a
lot of people never got past it
prod and you poked at it exploring the
limits of your reach and your strength
trying to find a way up and over and
there's a sense of truth in that lack of
compromise most obstacles in video game
worlds are fake you can be completely
confident in your ability to get through
them once you have the correct method or
the correct equipment or just by
spending enough time every pixelated
obstacle in sexy hiking is and again
keep on trying don't let it get to me
sir uh-huh uncle uncle Thane you don't
I'm gonna get you I've really got the
hang of it do you get me and my amazing
humor oh boy no oh yes wait yes I'm on
to something I'm on to something I'm on
to this
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
Oh dopamine is rushing through my brain
oh that feels good
how are you gonna make it feel bad wrong
way wrong way ah no why do you keep
doing that no no no stop what are you
doing what are you doing stop what
you're doing and don't do that thing
that you're done oh no no no no no no
how and why did you do that thing you
just did it's not where we're supposed
to be but I'll take it you like to make
sudden movements don't you Bennet bobbly
hiking your unyielding and that makes
the game uniquely frustrating but I'm
not sure jazz Row intended to make a
frustrating game the frustration is just
essential to the act of climbing and
it's authentic to the process of
building a game oh where am I going the
whole thing happened to me as I was
building this mountain
I'd have an idea for a new obstacle and
build it test it and I would usually
turn out to be unreasonably hard but I
couldn't bring myself to make it easier
it already felt like my inability to get
past a new obstacle was my fault as a
player rather than as a builder
imaginary mountains built themselves
from that if it's the climate and it's
our repeated attempts to reach the
summit that turns those mountains into
something real are you being
philosophical here are you being
philosophical I'm struggling my aim is
off no nope nope that ain't it that
ain't the one that ain't the way when
you build a video game world you're
building with ideas and that can be like
working with quick-set cement you mold
your ideas into a certain shape that can
be played with and in the process of
playing with them they begin to harden
and set until they're immutable like
rock and at that point you can't change
the world not without breaking it into
pieces and starting fresh with new ideas
just gotta pull myself up using sheer
friction friction oh you are an obstacle
oh no oh oh okay all right
rethink this kind of thing through this
yes yes no yes no yes no yes no yes stop
no I just want to very carefully very
carefully set my ass down there this is
where I could lose it all
we'll see see see it's a little it's a
little off-kilter
so I need to make sure I'm where I
should be and then shoot Luffy is now
people have been predicting that games
would soon be made out of prefabricated
objects bought in a store and assembled
into a world and for the most part that
hasn't happened because the objects in
the stores are trash I don't mean they
look bad or that they're badly made
although a lot of them are I mean
they're trash in the way that food
becomes trash as soon as you put it in
the sink these are made to be consumed
and used in a certain context and once
the moment is gone they transform into
garbage in the context of technology
those moments pass by in seconds oh how
how do i over time we've poured more and
more refuse into this vast digital
landfill that we call the Internet wait
in now vastly outnumbers in our ways the
things that are fresh and untainted and
unused when everything around us is
cultural trash trash becomes the new
medium the lingua franca of the digital
age you could build culture out of trash
but only trash culture be games be
movies be music be philosophy oh this is
what digital culture is a monstrous
mountain of land filled with everything
we ever thought of in it grand infant
and unsorted
I don't think I've said a word in the
past few hours
noises oh why oh why can't I do this
anymore no no no oh god he says no oh
all right hey oh whoa whoa whoa no no no
what are you doing what are you doing no
no what are you doing what are you doing
stop no oh god [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
No there we go
okay okay all right we're back we're
back in business back in business this
guy is so strong this guy's so strong
because of how strong I am
that's how strong he is this is how
strong I am
oh no I don't mean I'm not trying to do
that one fast it just because the ledge
is there it like suddenly I'm trying to
do that so slow and it just I'll shut up
with the goddamn music I hate you I hate
you I hate you I hate you game no stop
stop no stop playing that stupid music I
don't care what you're singing about I
don't care what you're doing I don't
care about anything other than it's
because of that lip of the roof on that
part makes this really difficult it
makes it surprisingly difficult okay I
must set myself on this yes and then I'm
gonna lift just like
oh that's knob go fast that's nice it's
3d models of breakfast genexus fanfic
novels scan magazines green screen Shia
LaBeouf Ben's stuff scenes on liveleak
Facebook's got lifelike BOTS with
unbranded adverts and candid shots of
Kanye and Taylor Swift mashups car crash
epic failed gifs Russian dash cam video
mcribs discarded forgotten unrecycled
muddled rotten untitled everything's
fresh for about six seconds until some
newer thing beckons and we hit refresh
and there's years of persevering
disappearing into the pile out of style
out of sight nice slam poem I'm about to
slam this goddamn hammer
oh my god no no no I'm not moving my
mouse I'm not moving my god damn else
why why why why would you do that to me
I I hate I hate I hate everything about
you hey everything see sometimes they
move so fast I don't know why
real real careful no that's gonna slip
that's gonna slip yep there goes okay so
that slipped because of course it would
slip it makes sense that it's slipped
[Music]
okay you know what I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
I'm done no I'm not done
no I'm done this is why can't you rage
games this is why I can't I can't do it
I can't do it I can't I can't do them I
can't do them I can't I can't do him
this is why I can't is why I can't this
is why I can't this is why I can't this
here is why I cannot do them I can't
there's not a joke I'm not joking I
never joke about this everything I do in
the rage game it's not a flippin joke
hate them I hate them so much
they're so bad for me emotionally they
take a toll on my soul not a joke okay
so anyway
that's all the time I got for this
episode if you want to see more let me
know in the comments below I'll probably
play more anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]